If you were born without half your brain doctors
wouldn't give you much chance for a normal
life, but a woman in China is proving them
all wrong!
Hey friends it's Trace!
Thanks for watching DNews.
You know how I talk about how awesomely awesome
the brain is at re-routing connections and
adapting?
Here's the perfect example.
A 24-year-old woman in China complained of
dizziness and nausea to a doctor and eventually
they put her in a CAT scanner -- she was missing
her WHOLE CEREBELLUM.
Are you freaking out yet?
The cerebellum sits below the two brain hemispheres
and contains 50 percent of all the neurons
in your brain.
Imagine if HALF your brain cells were just…
not there!
Scientists believe the cerebellum is how we
control our motor skills, maintain balance,
and manage speech.
They also believe it assists the two hemispheres
in emotion, memory and attention.
And this woman was born without one and yet
doctors say she’s not functionally disabled.
The study in the journal Brain explained the
woman doesn't have difficulty speaking and
coordinating her movements, and she didn't
learn to speak until she was six or walk until
seven -- but again, without the part of the
brain to control those things… it's a surprise
she learned at all!
This case is a testament to brain plasticity.
We've talked about this before, brain plasticity
is the ability of the human brain to compensate
for changes in environment or body, like learning
to walk again after a stroke, or, in this
case, learning to walk AT ALL without a motor
control center!
When you lose a finger, says iO9, the "neural
representations of neighboring fingers get
bigger."
But it’s commonly known that when you lose
one sense, the others heighten to compensate…
Still, how DID she learn to walk or speak
without the part of the brain for those tasks?
The doctors believe the functions normally
reserved for the cerebellum, were picked up
by the cerebral cortex -- the brain's outermost
layer.
Normally, the cortex assists in the regulation
of the motor controls, sensory information,
and association -- that is to say perception
of the world.
This case shows how plastic the brain really
is, in that this woman lives a relatively
normal life -- aside from her feelings of
dizziness and a mild mental impairment.
She was able to marry, have children, and
understands the world around her.
This is not the first case of a missing cerebellum;
there have been nine cases, starting in 1831.
Without CAT or MRI scans, most of the cases
were caught after death, like in 1940, when
a 76 year old was found to have lived his
whole life without a cerebellum.
Whether the woman will live to that age is
unknown, doctors will surely be studying her
progress moving forward, though.
Thanks to brain plasticity it's not just the
cerebellum that can go missing without affect...
WIRED magazine reported earlier this year
that a man who was born without the connections
between the two hemispheres of his brain is
88 and lives a relatively normal life.
A scientific case study written about him
suggests aside from trouble drawing or using
both hands at once he's lived a normal life.
In 2007, New Scientist reported a man's head
was basically a hole instead of a brain!
50 to 75 percent of his skull was full of
cerebrospinal fluid, with only a thin layer
of brain tissue running around the edge and
connecting through the middle.
And yet, he worked for the government and
had a family with two children.
The human body has an amazing capacity for
adaptation and survival.
Scientists would have said all of these people
should not have survived, but here they are,
living lives.
Does stuff like this shock you anymore?
Do you know more about this case?
Share with us in the comments, let's keep
following her progress!
Subscribe for more science every day of the
week!!
Thanks for watching DNews, y'all are great!